voici les voilà la viola à cames en
direct j'ai fait des films et surtout je
me suis fait des amis puis j'ai pour la
première fois expérimenté le juge dira
j'ai eu des amis dans ma vie mais j'ai
expérimenté le sentiment de l'a86 en
groupe
la bande le sentiment de deux bandes de
meute de solidarité de groupe
et puis j'avais envie à travers ce film
entre autres choses de leur rendre
hommage de rendre hommage à la force de
ses de ses amitiés la merci il ya
beaucoup de questions embarrassantes
on va commencer sur un côté gauche la
salle bonjour catherine beauchamp 98,5
coucou coucou et xavier deleu mentionné
hier après le film ça fait dix ans donc
on a pu voir j'ai tué ma mère qui était
présentée ici au festival de cannes
j'aimerais que tu ne parles un peu de
ton évolution au sein du festival et
aussi comme cinéaste au travers des dix
dernières années et je sais que tu avais
très envie de jamais j'avais très envie
soit mentionné que tu avais envie de
partager avec les acteurs le festival de
cannes alors chez curieuse d'entendre
pourquoi est il peut-être d impression
si tout ça bon alors je c'est sûr que
dia aujourd'hui quand je repense à notre
moment où on a débarqué sur la croisette
par exemple avec anne dorval à l'époque
de j'ai tué ma mère on était en train
venant d'une naïveté et puis d'une
mais avec quelque chose de vierges
évidemment dans notre façon de regarder
le festival de vivre le festival on en
connaissait rien puis on découvrait tout
à coup cette atmosphère dichotomique
chaotique de amalgame de cinéma mais
aussi de stars 2
et puis je regarde aujourd'hui les dix
ans fait qu'ils ont passé depuis avec
des passages au festival avec certains
des films que j aime que j'ai réalisé
puis évidemment j'ai j'ai appris
énormément j'ai rencontré surtout
énormément de jeu fait des rencontres
tellement profonde senti tellement
déterminante
ici au festival des amitiés qui se sont
qui se sont nouées qui ont débouché sur
des collaborations artistiques
puis le jury aussi qui est un passage
qui a été extrêmement marquant pour moi
peut-être l'expérience la plus la plus
forte ici au festival parce que parce
que j'avais passionnel présenter et
présenter un film c'est c'est dans une
très courte période rêvée des quelque
chose qu'on a qu'on a mis des mois des
nuits entières à pas dormir à réfléchir
à faire les cent pas ça demande une
grande part de d'énergie un don de soi
don de qui compte bien évidemment voir
des films autant de films de qualité en
si peu de temps c'est une expérience qui
est qui beaucoup moins tac sentent en
termes de stress en termes de titres et
luxuriante que le festival veut très
très agréable pour pour les membres donc
le jury a été très très marquants et
puis aujourd'hui ben je peux enfin après
dix ans c'est pas que je me suis lassé
de quoi que ce soit on demande est ce
que c'est si répétitives cette
expérience à chaque fois ça ça
recommence parce que le film conte à
porter est différente
l'expérience se renouvelle mais là j'ai
la chance de de pouvoir le partager avec
eux des gens que j'aime puis leur faire
vivre le bonheur le vertige aussi le
stress
le manque de sommeil le manque de
sommeil qui m'habite depuis maintenant
10 ans non mais non mais voilà donc je
sais pas comment répondre à ta question
cette espèce d'arc de 10 ans mais voilà
c'est un bonheur de pouvoir partager
avec avec des gens que j'aime avec qui
j'ai j'aime vivre avec qui j'aime fêter
rire parler mais avec qui maintenant
j'ai aimé plus que tout créé et
travailler à la création au milieu la
salle tout à fait à l'avant à i'm new
here you see you in may qui raconte
comment son film c'est un peu en même
temps une question personnelle en ce
sens qu il est entouré de sa bande
d'amis c'est ce qu'il a dit à qui
voulait exploiter ce sentiment de
fraternité comme ça c'est des gens qui
aiment bien se côtoyer fêter travailler
et créer ensemble alors mathias et
maxime c'est le reflet effectivement de
deux amis d'enfance qui tout à coup aux
tourments dans un film un court métrage
si je ne m'abuse s'embrassent et tout à
coup ça a créé des remous chez ces deux
hommes ces deux jeunes hommes je peux
pas vous en dire plus parce que très
honnêtement j'en sais pas plus alors on
nous au musée on est très à l'aise on ne
vous cache auriez là dessus et bon
puisqu'il répond des questions en
anglais
on va laisser libre court à cette
conférence de presse
et puis jean françois bélanger qui hélas
et sa caméra d'ailleurs avec sergio qui
nous offre ce point de presse de tous
les acteurs et actrices et la
productrice qui la blonde à gauche de
l'écran ici qui est répondent aux
questions des journalistes donc jean
françois
nous mettra au fait des propos de xavier
dolan au cours des prochaines minutes